é
[Música]
se vocês já fizeram essa pergunta e se
algum de vocês eu me faço essa pergunta
todos os dias pelo menos umas três vezes
por dia mas uma outra pergunta que que
eu gosto muito de fazer essa daqui onde
você se vê em oito anos
alguns de vocês aqui talvez acabara de
entrar na faculdade
outros talvez já estão se formando
alguns de vocês já são profissionais
casados
talvez alguns diretores de empresa
professores mas você já parou para
pensar aonde você pode estar ou aonde
você se vê em oito anos
engraçado dizer porque oito anos carlos
porque é basicamente onde está minha
história começa em algumas pessoas me
perguntam quem é o carlos com a história
dele de onde ele veio que ele fez que
ele representa e para algumas pessoas
elas acham que a história começou aqui
nessa foto que eu tirei da tática há
quatro anos atrás mas de fato não foi
nesse momento que a minha história
começou há oito anos atrás eu
trabalhando então uma empresa que
representava à época no brasil e foi
para uma reunião com o diretor 12
pessoas na reunião eu meu diretor e 10
mil engenheiros engenheiros eletrônicos
inclusive esses caras eles viam seus
responsáveis pela segunda empresa no
brasil a fabricar o iphone
todos estavam esperando e aguardando
para que pudesse ser produzido
aqueles meninos que se seguiam
absolutamente nenhuma das palavras que
foram ditas eu consegui entender que a
região inteira foi inglês
o meu diretor que já vem morar fora ele
então conduzir e toda aquela reunião e
eles iam e você já chegou à reta havia
atrasado de uma piada
eles então eu e ele estavam sério seu e
aquilo começou a incomodar e aquilo me
levou ainda pra pro meu passado eu
comecei a parar para pensar por que que
eu estava ali naquela situação sem
conseguir entender uma palavra quando
tinha 12 anos eu comecei a trabalhar e
não meu pai não explorava ele não se
quer pediu para fazer isso
eu que quis começar a trabalhar nada
mais justo do que com 12 anos trabalha
hoje trabalha em uma locadora de vídeo
eu ia pegar todos os jogos de videogame
de graça porque não e eu era menino que
colocava fita na sacolinha
essa é a minha responsabilidade era isso
que eu fazia e aí então eu comecei a
perceber que aquilo era uma
responsabilidade
só que eu já sabia colocar a sacolinha
já começou a ficar tranqüilo que eu
comecei a prestar atenção no todo da
locadora como que ele conversava com as
pessoas quando ele indicar um filme
algumas vezes a pessoa chega olha eu
quero aquele filme com aquele negro
assim alto e ele deve ser um ótimo eu
olhava para aquilo que ele sabe dos
filmes ainda fala inglês e chegava uma
mulher olha aquela moça linda de cabelos
pretos
eu olhava pra quem o 12 anos eu falava
meu deus é o cara tem um conhecimento eu
não consigo nem imaginar que aquilo pra
mim foi incrível porque olhava pra que
ele dizia eu quero aprender inglês
mas o tempo passou eo esquecido esse
sonho e naquele momento 12 pessoas
sentadas na mesa eu era o único que não
conseguia entender uma palavra às vezes
uma das coisas que mais o que mais nos
prejudica no dia a dia
foi essa palavrinha que inclusive foi
uma das primeiras que eu aprendi inglês
o medo talvez dos 12 anos até
aproximadamente 28 anos que eu tinha
naquela época eu tive medo e aquela
perguntinha do índice até então eu já
começava a se fazer mas eu não imaginava
como é que eu conseguiria responder uma
pergunta que eu de fato não conseguia
ver onde acabar um dia no futuro e é
isso que o medo faz com a gente
o medo faz com que você se do do vídeo
de você mesmo
mesmo antes de você tentar fazer alguma
coisa
quantos de vocês aqui talvez sonharam em
estudar na unidade
o mesmo de ser diretor ou presidente de
uma grande empresa mesmo talvez um
professor
quantos aqui já sonharam em ter um
namorado uma namorada ser conhecido no
trabalho na família
eu não sei quantos de vocês já pensaram
em algumas ou todas essas todas essas
coisas mas pra mim uma coisa que ficou
muito clara
eu precisava mudar eu precisava fazer
alguma coisa
aqueles 45 minutos daquela reunião pra
mim foi intermináveis
como eu não entendi o que ele estava
dizendo a minha cabeça foi a milhão
e aí eu lembrava de uma palavrinha que
tinham me dito no passado mas a minha
concepção era algo tão estranho a
respeito daquela palavra não sei quanto
vocês sabe o que significa
pra mim e intercâmbio aí pra dizer eu
vou ser sincero pra vocês com 28 anos
não tinha intenção alguma de pra disney
mas era aquilo que eu entendia como
intercâmbio
eu conversei com um amigo disse assim eu
olha o que aconteceu nessa reunião e eu
expliquei pra ele eu disse pra ele é um
ganho muito dinheiro tem já sucesso tem
somente oito anos eu tenho isso eu tenho
tudo aquilo que a sociedade fala pra
gente que a gente tem que ter o tinha
mas eu disse para ele eu não me sentir
bem esses 45 minutos
ele foi o cara você tem que fazer um
intercâmbio você tem que fazer alguma
coisa diferente e esse meu amigo é
fantástico porque ele disse sabe quem
intercâmbio é claro que eu sei ele foi o
que é então eu disse a disney ele disse
oi você conquiste oito anos acha que o
intercâmbio para disney mas era aquela
minha concepção
ele então começou a me explicar de como
é a mudança como que tudo funciona
quando você então tomar uma decisão como
essa
eu dizia para ele falou meu amigo eu já
tenho uma estrutura eu já tenho um
trabalho tem casa tenho 28 anos eu sou
um executivo eu trabalho pra apple como
assim eu vou em todas as fábricas
produzindo apple no brasil produzindo
eletrônica no brasil e em uns o cara
responsável para ver se o processo que
os engenheiros planejaram está
funcionando como assim eu vou
simplesmente desistir
você está dizendo isso pra mim só que
quando ele começou a conversar comigo de
20 que veio na minha cabeça
bn por eu comecei a pensar naquilo que
eu disse
será que será que isso realmente o que
ele está querendo dizer eu voltei depois
de todos esses anos talvez a
oportunidade de aprender inglês
pessoal eu vou dizer muito sinceramente
pra vocês foi quando tomei a decisão
eu falei vou deixar tudo eu vou tirar
aqui no brasil nós falamos muito do
momento dramático do ano sabático eu
disponho não consigo um ano sabático mas
eu acho que eu consigo seis meses
logo depois daquela daquele papo com meu
amigo conversei com o meu diretor diz
que sempre olha eu tomei uma decisão
ele falou qual você não vai querer outro
momento né
eu disse não ao contrário eu eu não pedi
demissão preciso que eu preciso sair
daqui eu preciso eu comecei a me
perguntar durante o final de semana todo
depois de uma conversa com um amigo
enfim eu tomasse uma decisão de fazer um
intercâmbio aprender o inglês
o downhill os ares que aquela reunião
pra mim foi muito marcante ele disse pra
mim sabe que carlos eu ou não só permite
você para que você possa ir mas eu vou
fazer mais
portanto só ficar falando em seis meses
ele disse quando você voltar as atenções
para garantir que era tudo o que eu
queria eu queria assumiu isso eu queria
aprender inglês e eu queria o que eu
queria ter a estabilidade do que de
voltar e ter um emprego
quem aqui nunca é isso quem aqui não
quer arriscar e fazer coisas desse nesse
estilo e falar senão vai ser alguma
coisa errada eu posso que eu volto para
onde eu estava e aí que tem um problema
durante esses seis primeiros meses que
eu fui fazer intercâmbio tiveram duas
coisas ficaram na minha cabeça
rodando rodando rodando e pra mim
pessoal família e amigos era
extremamente importante
nunca me preocupei muito com quanto eu
ganhava
nunca me preocupei muito com a posição
que exercia
mas quando você está fora sozinho sem
família sem amigos
eles fazem uma diferença gigante eu sei
que você ama o seu irmão sua irmã
eu sei você de repente aquela amiga que
sempre pega a roupa do seu guarda roupa
aquele amigo que sempre tira sarro você
pode cabelo mas essas pequenas coisas
pequenos detalhes
eles fazem uma diferença enorme quando
você está lá fora e eu comecei a fim de
que o pior que aconteceu eu não tinha
ideia que pudesse acontecer
só que eu cheguei lá eu queria aprender
inglês
eu ia para a escola aconteceu o que eu
aprendi inglês eo praticado ea vergonha
com 28 anos praticar em inglês montar de
novo para a escola já tinha informado
era um alto executivo que eu ganhava
dinheiro imaginem como foi pra mim
a falta de família e de amigos e ao
mesmo tempo passar um período aprendendo
uma língua que é completamente diferente
pra mim e aí foi quando eu percebi uma
coisa boba
normalmente nós temos o nosso primeiro
nome eo meu é carlos mas brasileiro um
pouco é o segundo nome trabalho e nós
brasileiros fazendo exatamente isso não
importa onde nós estamos nós sempre
vamos querer ajudar fazer trabalhar
é isso que a gente faz e comigo não foi
diferente ea tim que aconteçeu bom olhei
pra mim e falei estou aqui estou fazendo
inglês só aprendendo mas bom preciso
trabalhar né
e aí que aconteceu pessoal alguém
consegue adivinhar qual foi meu primeiro
trabalho pois é alto-executivo no brasil
ganhava muito bem
cheguei então onde o pessoal foi para a
austrália e lá na austrália primeira
semana foi tentar lhe um emprego 0 só
esse é o meu primeiro emprego
lava jato eu cheguei lá e um
simplesmente comecei a cip não vou falar
isso isso isso isso vai estar o que de
qualquer maneira tem um papelzinho no
bolso
se eu errar eo óleo e aí eu cheguei ali
o cara
o seu caso aí eu lavava blá blá blá blá
blá blá blá blá blá blá blá blá
ok eu olhei pra ele tem o fundo dos
olhos dele disse ok 35 segundos depois
eu coloquei a mão no meu rosto disse
o que que eu vou fazer estes hoje
pessoal no chão um brasileiro
ele dizia fica tranquilo que eu te
explico e aquilo pra mim foi assim o
cara olhou de novo pra mim e dizer ok
e aí eu fui de encontro brasileiro
brasileiro foi me cumprimentar
brasileira sua sede social né ele foi o
cara tudo quem foi que sua mão e um
abraço aqui pelo amor também é publicado
essa me salvou
ele então colocada ele só pediu para
você passar nada mais nada menos ele só
pediu para você passar o aspirador que o
outro rapaz vai lavar e outro rapaz vai
julgar eu só isso disse ok pessoal em
menos de duas semanas eu era o melhor
cara que passava o aspirador nos carros
para isso eles nunca tinham visto o cara
passar o melhor operador que eu só
comecei a pensar futebol mão molhada pé
molhado ele toda hora ele começou a me
mover para o é ele promoveu então já não
era o cara que passa a respirar dor já
era o cara lavada pois o cara que lava
jato e jogando entendeu eu já era o cara
que estava naquela ferrari ali passava e
tal e por alguns segundos eu me sentia
muito bem só que ele não estava molhada
o tempo todo
começou a ficar complicado aí que o que
é a segunda coisa que o brasileiro faz o
brasileiro trabalha com a segunda coisa
que a gente faz
nós somos criativos o brasileiro nunca
nunca nunca desisti de ser criativo e aí
eu pensei como um outro emprego que eu
vou fazer
logicamente eu me tornei o que é
combatendo é que sabe fazer caipirinha
andré ninguém
uma pessoa que eu vou dizer pra vocês eu
sabia fazer caipirinha e o que acabou
acontecendo foi que eu me tornei o
melhor cara fazendo caipirinha no barco
fui só que aí o brasileiro faz o que o
que o objetivo agora o inglês já vão
começar a acontecer
só faltava uma coisa que era o que eu
queria beijar ver e conhecer uma moça
trabalhando à noite que você faz não
conhece muita gente que eu pelo menos
não com as pessoas que vão estar livre
quando você está aí que eu pensei eu
falei vou cuidar de novo e aí eu fui pra
mim o terceiro a produção na austrália
que foi o fotógrafo
aí eu comprei meu primeiro caminhão e
pessoal foi quando tarde e tudo começou
a acontecer
dezoito meses depois eu estava na
austrália eu tinha tomado a decisão
então meu inglês não estava bom e eu já
não falava inglês ruim mas não era bom
torneio e precisam de ficar mais mais do
que aqueles seis meses ninguém que o meu
chefe disse assim então sabe aquela vaga
que você deixou pra mim ele disse claro
e aí quando estava voltando a descer
não estou voltando vou ficar por aqui um
tempo maior e aí o que eu fiz vou fazer
uma especialização em tecnologia da
informação já era formado gostava de
tecnologia pensei comigo por que não
mas aí eu fui contra um caminhão só que
com o decorrer do tempo o segundo
caminhão foi encontrado o terceiro
caminhão foi comprado quarto caminhão
foi encontrado
só que o primeiro caminhão
a minha vida enquanto isso aqui você já
comeu hoje interessante quanto aqui de
vocês já comeram hoje no café da manhã
eu não vou perguntar o almoço e na janta
porque seria mais fácil mas quando saí
já comeram hoje no café da manhã o
almoço na janta por duas semanas
nenhuma mão pois foi exatamente o que
aconteceu comigo
o fato de eu não saber as leis do país
quando eu comprei aquele primeiro
caminhão e não sabia que eu tinha que
fazer o registro dele e para fazer o
registro você tinha que ter um caminhão
perfeitas condições
agora tive um brasileiro que não tinha o
caminhão em perfeitas condições
eu investir todo o dinheiro que eu tinha
tudo que eu tinha economizado e por duas
semanas depois que eu fiz eu comi e hoje
no café da manhã almoço e na janta
até hoje eu tenho no meu escritório na
austrália eu tenho um pacote de miojo
porque ele faz o que comigo ele faz me
lembrar
ele faz me lembrar isso daqui o que
aconteceu comigo oito anos depois aquela
pergunta do início e se hoje oito anos
depois eu consigo responder ela eu não
sei o que vai acontecer para você daqui
oito anos
eu não sei onde você estava oito anos
atrás mas uma coisa eu posso dizer pra
vocês
existem várias pessoas que por causa da
minha decisão que por causa da minha
resposta
a vida dela está mudando elas estão se
conectando algumas dessas pessoas eu
tenho na austrália 100 famílias que
dependem daquela resposta de oito anos
atrás as pessoas não pergunto caras como
isso pode ter acontecido por causa disso
pessoal
será que você se permite responder essa
pergunta e se eu fizer algo diferente
daquilo que alguém finou e em si eu de
fato tomar a decisão e assumir as
conseqüências
isso chama-se legado pessoal legado é
quando você deixa sua marca por onde
você passa onde você está
aquilo que você faz as pessoas que você
se conecta aquelas que dependem ou não
de você
essa palavrinha aqui e eu comecei a
parar e pensar o que pra mim significa
legado
algumas pessoas hoje olham pra mim e
acho que tudo que aconteceu na minha
vida foi por acaso
hoje muitas empresas que eu administro
de tecnologia da informação eu trabalho
com inteligência artificial e trabalho
com o blog ainda trabalha com
tecnologias que estão trabalhando em são
francisco nos estados unidos e ainda
assim pessoas acham que aconteceu ontem
que foi do dia pra noite não pessoal
a resposta do esse pra mim levou oito
anos para começar a perceber o quão
importante ela foi e por isso eu coloco
inclusive aquele macarrãozinho bem
bonito no meio àquele fácil lembrar a
cada dia ea cada momento
quando você toma uma decisão você
precisa se planejar algumas pessoas
olham essas fotos e ela se começa a
falar mas agora quero ter sucesso
só porque eu tô aqui com o embaixador do
brasil ministro da tecnologia da
austrália o mesmo quando eu fui citado
quando o senhor do ano na austrália o
brasileiro oito anos atrás sem falar uma
palavra em inglês foi citado como fim do
ano mas sabe quando olha essas fotos que
elas trazem pra mim que elas mostram a
única coisa que nós mostram que eu sou o
cara mais formais alto da porta
porque é isso que deve acontecer na sua
vida
o que você tem o que você representa não
deveria significar o seu legado não é
isso que fica como marca quando você
responde
d a pergunta do em si é exatamente isso
o meu colega falou isso você não
consegue chegar a lugar algum sozinho eu
não estou onde estou sozinho
eu talvez de pessoas que passaram por
várias coisas comigo e algumas delas
permanecem comigo mas eu tenho certeza
que muitas outras ainda vão passar
quando eu faço palestras pelo brasil o
pessoal me pergunta carlos posso
trabalhar com você e eu digo isso pra
ela só o pessoal olha isso aqui você
nunca sabe o que pode abrir a porta que
pode o que pode ter a outra porta e
quando ela disse eu posso trabalhar com
você a primeira coisa que eu pergunto
pra ela que responde o seu em si
a pergunta é se daqui pra ela você já se
está a fim hoje
quantas vezes
qual é o seu desafio qual é o tamanho do
seu sonho
qual é o tamanho do seu desafio talvez
hoje os meus desafios são diferentes
daqueles de oito anos atrás
aonde eu só queria o quê é só queria
aprender inglês
eu comecei o dia desses uma palestra
muito parecida com essa inglês e as
pessoas começaram a olhar umas para as
outras e diziam que o inglês
eu comecei a perceber um outro de cada
uma delas exatamente aqueles 35 segundos
iniciais do que de oito anos atrás
quando estava em uma reunião
eu não conseguia falar uma palavra
inglesa 45 segundos foram suficientes
para quem promover aquele sentimento que
eu tinha desde os 12 anos
talvez um dia vou até encontrar o dez é
um hotel de luxo onde eu vou contar essa
história pra ele que por causa dele eu
resolvi
o sonho mais pessoal o mais importante
pra vocês é o que as pessoas vão dizer
que vocês estão errados
as pessoas até onde sei talvez a mesma
coisa que ele fala pra mim casos e louco
eu tenho os negócios que eu tenho na
austrália o ano passado decidiu investir
no brasil todo mundo olhava pra mim
falar você é louco eu falo tem alguma
dúvida
lógico que eu sou louco só que eu sou
louco que é aí faz a diferença
vocês e dono de uma empresa ou você ter
funcionários não significar nada sabe o
que significa o pessoal está aqui tudo
que eu faço hoje na minha vida é pura
paixão
hoje eu consigo a cada dos 100% do meu
tempo 50% deles eu dedico ao meu grupo
de empresas mas sabe que eu faço todo 50
por cento exatamente isso que estou
fazendo aqui agora estava no brasil em
abril
eu já estou aqui de novo porque eu
preciso compartilhar eu preciso fazer
parte dessa mudança essa mudança tão
necessária que a gente precisa do brasil
é não importa o que está no governo quem
é o prefeito eu não me importo com a
faculdade não me importo com o seu
estado social com o nome do seu pai e da
sua mãe
não importa sequer se você tem ou não
tem dinheiro
nós como brasileiros nós somos
reconhecidos no mundo inteiro como um
grupo de pessoas não só extremamente
inteligentes amáveis sociais
mas o que eu começo a perceber isso aqui
nós temos paixão nós somos o tipo de
pessoa que quando a gente atravessa a
rua e tropeça alguém ajuda se olha para
a pessoa fala brigado que você tá
fazendo nada como fazer um churrasco
embora ea gente com outras coisas
tudo que a gente faz é compaixão eu vejo
muitos brasileiros fazendo o oposto que
eles odeiam brasil que eles odeiam os
brasileiros que eles odeiam político que
eles odeiam o governo que ele está
errado o que a gente precisa mudar é a
resposta da pergunta é individual em si
e se você tomar a dianteira do seu
círculo de amigos e se há cinco ou dez
pessoas que tiveram seu redor
começar a pensar da mesma forma se nós
fizemos algo diferente
eu acabei de ficar sabendo que o pessoal
está criando um grupo chamado ita rs e
no ita ex nada mais são do que seis
alunos que estão se unindo para fazer
aquilo que os estados unidos venceram o
mundo inteiro em investir na faculdade
que eles se formaram para que a que mais
e mais pessoas façam da mesma forma
a grande questão pessoal é o seguinte
quando tudo muda e eu eu sou uma pessoa
muito objetiva todos que trabalham
comigo sabem disso
tudo mudou pra mim com carros de oito
anos atrás
é absolutamente inexistente eu não
escrevi um livro e para ser muito
sincero pra vocês eu leio muito mas eu
não consigo às vezes parar para me
conter
o que eu vou fazer daqui agora em diante
tudo pra minha paixão tudo o que é
planejado na minha vida é executado
depois daqueles 12 anos de idade que eu
queria aprender inglês e eu fiquei com
tantos anos esperando eu nunca vai fiz o
mesmo pessoal olha onde estou hoje com
36 anos
olha o que aconteceu comigo oito anos
depois por causa de uma decisão que eu
tomei
amanhã talvez vocês vão estar aqui no
meu lugar amanhã seu pai sua mãe e seu
esposo ou esposa ou namorada sua
namorada
mesmo aquele namorado que diz que nessa
pode ficar em casa ou mesmo aquela
namorada e falei você não precisa de
outra promoção aquelas pessoas que te
amam que às vezes colocam para baixo
porque eles não gostam de você não é
esse motivo é porque eles têm o que o
medo ele pode servir para duas coisas
muito simples ele pode servir para
motivar a falar ah é que eu não vou
fazer
lógico que eu vou fazer olmedo pode
trazer o outro lado bom já que é muito
arriscado fazer
eu acho que eu vou ficar quietinho eu
prefiro que é claro que eu não tenho
oportunidade do que eu buscava
oportunidade e eu digo pra vocês sem
sombra de dúvidas eu tive pessoas que
acabaram de assistir uma palestra e
pedir emprego três meses depois estava
na austrália empregados por mim porque
eu posso a eu quero estar com os
melhores e assim como eu são todos os
empresários do mundo o país brasil é
apenas um pedaço do mundo pessoal
quando você responder à sua pergunta e
se pensar global não existem mais
barreiras
vocês estão aqui hoje podem estar seis
meses talvez como eu
estudando uma nova língua fazendo um
mestrado
como nosso amigo foi para a arábia
saudita ele hoje pra mim é uma
referência a todos os momentos em
qualquer lugar que eu tiver eu estiver
conversando então com alguém eu vou
citar ele
logicamente se eu puder convidado para
palestrar em algum lugar eu vou porque
porque é isso que nós devemos fazer
nossa vida a fazer o que a compartilhar
aquilo que é importante pra mim o que é
importante responder essa pergunta e se
abrigar
[Aplausos]